hi everyone i'm here outside the
broadcast center because we have a very
big surprise planned it's
mother's day coming up and we wanted to
celebrate
by helping some moms let loose and go
wild and by let loose and go wild
i mean literally having the day for
themselves we have three deserving moms
who are lifelong friends and we're gonna
surprise them
with a day out that they will never
forget oh here they come
how long have you guys been friends our
parents were actually
friends and how do you guys know each
other is it
true that this will feel like a wild and
crazy day
simply just that your kids are being
watched by someone else and it's not all
on your shoulders
yes i mean i heard you even take a car
ride
your only quiet time so are you ready to
have
a mom's day out yeah
oh my god here comes your chariot now
[Applause]
hello thank you
take good care of them let them have
some fun and we'll check in with you
throughout the hour
god i want to get on that bus ladies hi
we're loving our onesies we're so comfy
uh did you hit magnolia bakery one of
these cupcakes
yes amazing thank you
we love cupcakes children aren't here to
steal them that's the best part
by the way i ate a cupcake over my
kitchen sink the other night i was like
low point or awesome um
are you enjoying some uh coffee oh my
gosh
partying very good honey thank you
my kind of mom times out when you're at
home and you just want to
you know escape reality and get into
your happy place
what do you guys usually watch on tv
uh the real housewives watches bravo
all the housewives yeah my guiltiest
pleasure
our favorite is new jersey
i love it pretty funny because i've got
someone who wants to say hello to you
please welcome the real housewives of
new jersey star
melissa gorga hello
you guys are so cute are you having the
best day
yes i wanted to bring a little jersey
for you i crossed the bridge just come
say hi
this is so fun where'd you guys go so
far magnolia
magnolia oh my god i love magnolia okay
so good and you're just going to start
traveling around today
yeah we don't know it's a big secret
that is waiting so nice of drew i love
this
yeah so cute you're our first surprise
yeah i heard that you guys don't get out
a lot your wife's and moms and
oh my god nothing is like it's the
hardest job in the world i always say
that
um and then you go crazy because you
just hear babies in your ear all day and
you just want to hear some you want
adult time
right sometimes you just need a good
girl's day
well ladies it looks like you're having
a good time
hi melissa how are you
i'm so glad you guys are all together
keep rolling
keep rolling ladies how you doing
what location are you at now
that's right you're on fifth avenue one
of the best shopping destinations
in the world and i know as a mom that
you never really leave a store with
something for yourself because it's
always for the kids right
yes right now you're parked outside of
the coach
flagship store on fifth avenue and our
friends at coach
are giving each of you a 2
500 gift card to go inside
[Applause]
i can't believe that you came and did
this with us
thank you to you we are all such big
fans and we're also very grateful
to the big bus tours of new york i
love the convertible lifestyle
yeah so cool thank you to christine
vitale michelle brady and tara andretta
and thank you to melissa gorga for
coming on board
the real housewives of course new jersey
airs wednesday
at 9 8 central on bravo
um everybody loves that show and just
happy mother's day thank you
[Music]
you